donc Bill les gens pensent que vous êtes
fous d'avoir quitté les Rolling Stones
quand je suis allé dans rejoindre le
groupe les gens ont cru que j'étais fou
de de d'aller avec eux donc c'est la
même chose
tous ces titres sont extraits de l'album
forty-x les Rolling Stones bravo Bill
Wyman donc vous avez été pendant 30 ans
le bassiste des Rolling Stones voilà de
1962 à 1993 et vous avez été aussi Bill
Wyman l'archiviste du groupe vous
gardiez tout les photos l'étiquette
concert les affiches les pochettes de
disques et aujourd'hui vous publiez tout
ça dans un livre album qui s'appelle
rolling with the stone la saga d'un
groupe mythique s'est édité chez EPA
alors c'est un véritable album de
famille 512 pages 3000 photos vous avez
écrit le texte avec Richard rivers et
c'est la première biographie d'un groupe
vu de l'intérieur c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire
en effet et c'était nécessaire
de livres ont été écrits sur les Stones
mais rien n'était tout à fait tout à
fait vrai
je voulais faire la version authentique
et avoir une version très illustrée et
très différente de tous les autres
alors vous dites quand j'ai commencé à
collectionner les trucs des Stones
c'était pour montrer à mon petit garçon
Stéphane que son père avait passé un an
ou deux dans un groupe pop et vous avez
passé 31 ans
pour faire de la musique on voulait pas
être riche ou célèbre c'était pas le but
du jeu et même de faire de tenir plus de
5 ans et on s'y attendait pas du tout
c'est dit deux ou trois ans peut-être
maximum alors j'ai gardé des petites
choses ici et là des souvenirs pour le
gamin il avait 8 mois à l'époque quand
j'ai quand j'ai rejoint le groupe
et puis
j'ai continué il a continué à grandir et
puis au bout d'un certain moment il
s'intéressait plus à tout ça parce que
c'était sa vie en fait donc moi j'ai
continué à collectionner les les
souvenirs je crois que je suis le le
seul le seul membre du groupe d'un
groupe des années 60 qui est
collectionné quoi que ce soit un boulot
de moines ce qu'il a fait c'est
extraordinaire
la saga des Rolling Stones vous racontez
votre départ du groupe après quelques
albums
solo dans celui-là d'ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le sud de la France et donc je
m'étais mis à pauvre français il y a
quelques il y a un peu de Français
franglais disons
tout le monde a bien aimé vous habitiez
à Saint-Paul-de-Vence vous êtes devenus
amis avec Chagall le peintre Chagall
c'était vraiment un pote à vous quoi oui
nous sommes restés 8 dernières années de
sa vie dans les gens pensent que vous
êtes fous d'avoir quitté les Rolling
Stones
le groupe les gens ont cru que j'étais
fou de d'aller avec eux donc c'est la
même chose
au bout de 31 ans 31 ans ça suffisait
me remarier
et je me suis remarié
j'ai trois filles ravissantes maintenant
8 7 et 50 est-ce que je suis très
heureux est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé
depuis 1993 de le regretter d'avoir
quitté les Rolling Stones
aujourd'hui sur scène aujourd'hui sur
scène qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
je vois les Rolling Stones sur scène en
tant que public est-ce que est-ce que
vous regrettez l'humour de Mick Jagger
quand il vous disait que vous aviez plus
d'énergie pour jouer au ping-pong que
sur scène
non
d'ailleurs
13 disait à mon sujet d'abord on dit que
je ressemblais à
l'entrepreneur de pompes funèbres c'est
vrai on disait ça
me déplace que pour respirer
et c'était un peu vrai aussi on disait
aussi que vous étiez rentré dans les
Stones au départ parce que vous étiez le
seul à avoir de quoi vous payer un ampli
j'avais les emplis les
haut-parleurs et les deux autres amplis
je les ai donné au groupe c'était très
content
j'ai amené c'est moi qui ai électrifié
qui a porté l'électricité au groupe
est-ce que vous regrettez qu'on
connaisse moins votre groupe les rythme
Kings que les Rolling Stones
avec le public tout prêt des choses plus
intimes et puis j'aime bien jouer toutes
sortes de musique différentes
et ce qui me plaît aussi c'est d'avoir
le public à proximité passe un petit
grain de sable comme ça au loin si sinon
ça je ferais pas ça je resterai chez moi
avec ma famille alors dans ce groupe les
référenkins il y a quand même georgiène
celui qui chantait yeah papa papa papa
papa papa papa assey
et donc vous êtes en tournée en France
au mois de juin et à l'Olympia mesdames
Messieurs le 26 juin voilà est-ce que
vous auriez pris être le bassiste des
Beatles c'était ma prochaine question
Gérard c'est un génie tu es un génie
absolue regarde est-ce que vous
regrettez de pas avoir fait partie des
Beatles
[Applaudissements]
dès le départ
avant d'avoir fait le premier album on
était déjà copain avec eux et nous
sommes encore amis avec eux Giorgia
Arsen a joué dans mon dernier album de
Kings j'ai vu Ringo il y a quelques
semaines en quelques mois
il a son propre groupe
est-ce que vous regrettez que les jeunes
aujourd'hui n'écoutent plus que du rap
c'est que les médias ne permettent pas
aux jeunes d'écouter à d'autres musiques
c'est ça le problème en fait
aussi le ferai bien sûr
Bertille va beaucoup en ce moment ça
marche à mort
elle Georges
est-ce que vous regrettez l'attitude de
Tony Blair dans le conflit irakien
et quand il a été élu poste de Premier
ministre je l'ai appelé yogi l'ourson et
donc ces derniers
quoi alors aujourd'hui billwayman vous
vous consacrez à vos restaurants qui
s'appelle les Sticky Fingers comme le
fameux disque des Stone avec la pochette
de Warhol avec la fermeture éclair VIP
et puis vous consacrez aussi au rythmen
Kings votre votre groupe à vos livres
vous partagez entre Londres et puis
votre château dans le dans le succès
vous avez un château et alors on est
loin quand même de vos origines on est
loin du William purgs de lewyn Sham dans
le sud-est de Londres vous avez une
enfance très très dure votre père était
briquetier votre mère était domestique
puis ouvrière et vous avez eu une
enfance dans la pauvreté je crois que
chez vous il y avait qu'une seule brosse
à dents pour toute la famille
c'était pendant la Guerre
mondiale donc
mon enfant je l'ai passé pendant la
guerre sous les bombes
il y avait cinq enfants à la maison il y
avait pas beaucoup d'argent et vous
aviez souvent chez votre chez votre
grand-mère qui avait votre grand-mère
avait un écran de télévision c'était un
des premiers qui a eu j'ai 15 cm et pour
agrandir l'image il y avait un autre
écran par dessus incurvé rempli d'eau
de cricket et de foot
les joueurs étaient miniatures quand
même malgré l'agrandissement
mais c'est tout ce qu'on avait donc on
faisait avec voilà et c'est là c'est
votre grand-mère qui vous fait jouer du
piano de la clarinette et qui vous
inscrit au Royal Collège de musique et
quand vous arrivez dans ce Royal Collège
vous avez un problème parce que vous
avez un accent cockney les autres se
moquent de vous vous essayez de prendre
l'accent des riches et après quand vous
retournez chez les pauvres il se moque
de votre accent de riche donc c'est un
peu compliqué comme époque exact
exactement
la vie est difficile en général alors
billwayman vous avez vécu en France donc
à Saint-Paul-de-Vence vous aimez la
cuisine française
mais ça tombe bien parce qu'on va vous
faire une interview fromage ou dessert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors interview fromage ou dessert
est-ce que vous préférez Mick Jagger ou
qui switcher
est un petit peu comme le celui qui vous
bouscule à l'école la brute de l'école
et plus compréhensif
si vous aviez un problème par exemple
j'étais au Japon en 1990 et mon père est
mort pendant que j'étais là-bas
Charlie
m'ont beaucoup aidé les autres m'ont pas
tellement aidé donc c'est quelqu'un de
bien quand on a vraiment besoin de
quelqu'un il est là c'est pour ça que je
l'aime mieux est-ce que vous préférez
votre carrière solo à vous ou la
carrière solo de Mick Jagger
que lui c'est vrai est-ce que vous
préférez jouer avec les ruissements
Kings devant 3000 personnes à l'Olympia
ou avec les Rolling Stones devant 60 000
personnes au Stade de France
l'Olympia est-ce que vous préférez être
le Stone silencieux puisque c'était
votre surnom ou le Stone avec une grande
bouche et des pantalons moules [__]
le côté célébrité et compagnie c'est pas
mon truc c'est difficile quand on est
une star est-ce que vous préférez les
Stone ou les Beatles
sur scène
mais je préfère les disques des Bitcoin
en studio très juste il a parfaitement
raison est-ce que
la différence c'est légère mais c'est ma
préférence est-ce que vous préférez Lena
ou Macartney un lieu de me parler
je m'entendais mieux avec Paul
plus sympa plus sympa que John John
était quelquefois difficile est-ce que
vous préférez que je vous présente Macha
Méril Clara Morgane ou Julie de godresse
et voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
heureuse de vivre alors que les deux
autres sont tellement attirantes que
j'aurais probable des difficultés avec
mon mariage
[Rires]
et mes enfants et vous préférez Vincent
ou moi
ok ok
[Rires]
merci
de ne rien rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu